Japan is lifting its nationwide state of
emergency is the number of daily
coronavirus cases there keeps dropping
the country has reported just 830 deaths
hundreds of miles away taiwan has had
remarkable success in its response to
the pandemic it is reported only listen
to this number seven deaths Holly
Williams reports how they did that on
the island of Taiwan the streets are
bustling restaurants are open for diners
schools only shut down for two weeks in
February and even the baseball season is
in full swing though one team
temporarily relied on mannequins
spectators with a population of nearly
24 million Taiwan's had just seven
deaths and with rapid contact tracing
fewer than 500 infections and that's
despite lying around 80 miles from
mainland China we have been planning for
and the reason is because of spec in
2003 I was hit very hard by sarees so
let me get this straight you had been
planning for a pandemic for 17 years yes
any Warner they already had a command
center ready to activate and generous
stockpiles of protective gear and
Taiwanese companies invested in
high-tech solutions like these robot
testing machines crucially the
government started warning the public of
how serious the new virus was back in
January the Health Minister even broke
down in tears as he announced a new
infection it appears like we were sort
of with our pants down professor Robert
Brooke is an American public health
expert who studied taiwan's response
they do everything they had so they
didn't have to scramble they didn't have
any hospital beds
how many ventilators where were the
equipment like love sand baths were how
many they had they were prepared they
had stockpiles they were ready as I
would say rock and roll Taiwan's
universal health care system keeps
records on every resident
marrying that with immigration data made
tracing infections much easier I tend to
believe that we need to share a lot more
data to prevent ourselves from having
catastrophic results when someone's
thing attacks us like a virus some have
argued that Asian governments have had
it easy because people there are
supposedly more obedient using Taiwanese
people are more obedient than people no
not at all
feminist democracy and Taiwan's
opposition is also very critical the
government but when it comes to public
health when the command center has
educated people enough they understand
what's the best for them
for CBS this morning Polly Williams
planning paying off in Taiwan